it's another week and that means it's
time for new releases marys at VidCon
this week so once again it looks like
you're stuck with me lucky for you it
sounds like there are some hot games
coming out this week if you prefer your
Star Wars stories the Lego formed and
get ready to experience the force
awakens as the iconic plastic toys this
is the fifth entry in the lego star wars
franchise and it will cover the events
of the seventh movie as well as bridge
the gap between episode 6 and episode 7
as with previous Lego games there are
plenty of characters you can play as
including rey finn han Solo kylo ren and
many more finish building what you
started on jun 28 ford get ready for it
playstation 4 xbox one playstation 3 wii
u nintendo 3ds xbox 360 playstation vita
and pc if you've seen the force awakens
too many times but you're still itching
for an epic sci-fi adventure than Star
Ocean integrity and faithlessness might
just scratch that itch as with previous
titles Star Ocean five blends fantasy
with the vast expanses of space
integrity and faithlessness takes place
in between the second and third entry on
a planet 6,000 light-years from Earth
the story revolves around a character
named Fidel as he makes first contact
with an advanced race if I was a betting
man I'd say it's up to Fidel and his
crew to save the universe you can pick
this one up for PlayStation 3 and
PlayStation 4 on the twenty-eighth it's
been six years since play dead released
their last game limbo and now we are
only a few short days from their next
game inside inside is about a boy trying
to uncover the mysteries of a dystopian
and oppressive world just like limbo
inside is a bleak puzzle platformer
sprinkled with gruesome death animations
and a beautiful monochromatic setting
inside comes to xbox one on jun 29th and
two windows on july seven
just when you thought you saw the last
of box boy you thought wrong the boy
shaped box or box J boy is back how
laboratories well receive puzzle
adventure game ups the ante with even
more boxes seriously now box boy can
bring us a whole nother set of boxes
where these boxes coming from will never
know but they are key in order to solve
the puzzles and save this boxing world
box box boy comes the Nintendo 3ds on
june thirtieth finally the next entry in
Coto ishiko she's zero escape series
comes out next week this one is called
zero time dilemma and takes place in
between the events of nine hours nine
persons nine doors and virtues last
reward zero time dilemma is an adventure
game that follows nine characters locked
in a fallout shelter forced to play a
deadly game haha c'mon game with him
jigsaw knows what's up the characters
are divided into three teams in in order
to escape you need six passwords the
trouble is the only way you can get
passwords is when someone dies if you
think you have the Wits to escape the
bunker you can pick that one up on jun
28 for 3ds playstation vita or pc let me
know which games you're most looking
forward to this week and remember these
dates are based on retailer listings and
sometimes they change it's a bummer I
know but there isn't much we can do
about that if you want to know we
thought of some of these games be sure
to head on over to gamespot com later in
the week until next time